لذا فإن الحوسبة الكمومية هي حوسبة
لا تستخدم رقائق الكمبيوتر ولكن تستخدم هذه
الموجات أو هذه
الحالات المختلفة لهذه الموجات، يمكن لهذه الموجات أن
تهتز في أي اتجاه وهي
متزامنة بحيث يمكنها في الواقع
حساب مكانين أو ثلاثة أماكن في
نفس الوقت  الوقت،
فكر في فأر في متاهة،
سيحسب الكمبيوتر الرقمي مسار
كل فأر في كل مفصل في كل
مكان حيث يوجد قرار يجب
اتخاذه ومتاهة الآن يستغرق الأمر إلى الأبد
الآن يقوم الكمبيوتر الكمي بتحليل
جميع الأوضاع الممكنة على الفور جميع
المسارات الممكنة  في الوقت نفسه
الآن، هذا ينتهك الفطرة السليمة، حيث
يقول إنه لا يمكنك أن تكون مكانين في
نفس الوقت، حسنًا،
يمكنك أن تكون في العديد من الأماكن في
نفس الوقت، وهذا هو ما
يمكن أن يكون عليه الكمبيوتر المحمول في نفس الوقت، وهذه هي قوة أجهزة
الكمبيوتر الكمومية.  تبدو متشابهة عندما
تنظر إلى الكمبيوتر الكمي، فهي مثل
الثريا، جهاز عملاق ولكن في
الواقع، تتم العملية الحسابية الفعلية في
الأسفل، ما هي هذه الثريا،
الثريا هي أنابيب تبريد
أنابيب التبريد لخفضها إلى ما يقرب من
الصفر المطلق حيث يوجد  لا توجد اهتزازات إذا
عطس شخص ما على بعد مبنى واحد مما قد
يفسد حساباتك بالكامل ولذا فأنت
تريد أن يتم تجميد كل شيء بالقرب من
الصفر المطلق